It's sad to have to bring this kind of video here.
But the little boy Gui is being attacked on
social networks because of Fluminense in morale.
Where do people go on football account?
Shy a little boy?
A child, bro.
Anyway,
let me explain to you what you recorded a video on
social networks congratulating Fluminense on the title,
I'll show the video to you and you draw your conclusions.
Picolé
from the heart.
, Fluminense,
congratulations on the 4th Libertadores,
congratulations.
And then,
after this video,
Gui had to release this statement,
In this case,
it was Gui Chato's parents.
When dealing with the public,
we have to ourselves,
even if we don't want to cause controversy.
Come on,
Gui is Basque.
Love your team and everyone can see it in their everyday lives.
My father and grandfather,
Gui's great-grandfather,
are tricolors,
in honor of him,
we made the video,
Gui can sing hymns for all teams and anyway,
he is a child who loves sport and Gui's great-grandfather is
ninety and three years old and he can see the team win the Libertadores.
Cês is aware of this and it is very sad to
see so many people criticizing and attacking.
A simple tribute to your loved ones.
Gui at no time disrespected the captain,
he just congratulated Fluminense.
Much because of your great-grandfather.
It has, right?
Ninety-three years and I saw a Libertadores title.
It's just phenomenal.
I honestly wouldn't have sung Fluminense's anthem,
I would have congratulated him the same way he did.
But I don't see any problems now.
Distilling hate in the guy kid is under ten years old,
new guy kid,
are you cursing?
Why where the internet goes,
man?
But anyway,
congratulations to Fluminense.
I didn't want to,
but then congratulations to you.